have you ever looked out your plane
window and wondered what the hell those
little curly bits at the end of the wing
were for the development of winglets as
we see them today started during the
1973 oil crisis the Arab states put an
oil embargo on the United States for
providing aid to Israel during the Yom
Kippur War
this caused oil prices to skyrocket
forcing engineers to get creative to
reduce fuel consumption enter Richard T
Whitcomb I could probably do an entire
video on this guy's contribution to
aviation but let's focus on his work
with winglets for now part of his
inspiration came from birds that curled
their wing feathers up while gliding to
achieve more lift so he got to work
testing this theory and found that it
worked exactly as he expected let's take
a look at the science as you probably
know from watching my previous videos
planes fly by developing high-pressure
air under their wings and low pressure
air above fluids will always flow from
high pressure regions to low pressure
regions and this can cause some problems
at the tips of the wing how you pressure
air from below will bleed into the low
pressure air above creating many
tornadoes off the tips of the wing this
is called induce drag and it decreases
the lift of the wing and increases the
fuel consumption of the plane wing let's
reduce this air flow by reducing the
pressure gradient at the tips of the
wings thus making the vortices much
smaller their ultimate goal is to create
a lift distribution across the wing in
the shape of an ellipse this minimizes
the amount of air that wants to flow
over the tips of the wing while
maintaining maximum lift let's compare
some wind shapes and their lift
distributions to see how this works
here are three wing shapes an elliptical
rectangular and triangular wing and
their lift distributions look like this
as you can see the elliptical wing also
has an elliptical lift distribution and
this is the ideal the iconic Spitfire
was one of the few mass-produced planes
in history to have this shape as it is
difficult and expensive to manufacture
the rectangular wings lift distribution
is quite high at the edges and this
leads to high levels of the juice drag
but this is the easiest shape of wing to
manufacture and is mostly used in
smaller cheaper aircraft our last wing a
triangular way has high lift in the
center which rapidly drops off towards
the edge this type of wing has low
induced drag but its lift distribution
is far from ideal
the ultimate goal is to tailor the lift
across the wing into the shape of an
ellipse to maximize lift and minimize
induced drag winglets are just one way
to do this
Boeing's latest plane the Boeing 787
Dreamliner has done away with winglets
in favor of a raked wingtip which sweeps
the tip of the wing backwards
Boeing have said that their raked
wingtips have improved fuel efficiency
by five point five percent over the four
point five percent for conventional
wingtips you can learn why this alters
the lift distribution by watching my
video wire plane wings angled backwards
if you'd like to learn more about the
cost of air travel check out this quick
preview for a video Wendover production
denied work done an airbus a320 burns
1.5 gallons of jet fuel for every mile
it fly so flying the 213 miles from New
York to DC burns 317 gallons or about
two gallons per person given average jet
fuel prices it only costs two dollars
and fifty cents and fuel for you to fly
from New York to DC so why do tickets
cost upwards of $80 well the short
answer is takeoff fees landing fees crew
costs taxes more taxes airplane fees
maintenance fees insurance costs even
more taxes and administrative costs if
you want the long answer well then come
over to my channel and watch my video
which includes a special appearance by
real engineering
you